with some of the gay lingo that women
are going to steal and act like it's
theirs in two years oh yeah um any
prepositions verbs
right now I don't know I mean I didn't
even understand like everyone's like
you're at a hard launch with your
boyfriend is that like oh yeah that's
the thing yeah I'm like hard launch what
I'm not like in Florida like and ten
nine like for me and my boyfriend yeah
so I don't know as opposed to the soft
launch you know what's the soft launch
this is like you're holding a hand or
something yeah like you post in your
story like the meal and then there's
someone in the picture
[Laughter]
yeah it's a soft launch so gross